sol zanetti d'un côté catherine dorion
de l'autre deux nouveaux venus à
l'assemblée nationale et ils viennent
comme ils sont quand même la politique
du monde au québec qu'on est en train de
faire du sisp au juste nous autres avec
vous autres jeux faisons ça dans le
petit coin
l'idée c'est pourquoi pas aller chercher
plus de monde en représentant une plus
large palette de mon s'y mettront aux
rentrées le déguisé en poulet ou en
girafe jeu qui est une atteinte au
décorum le décorum moi je suis de ceux
qui pensent et c'est une opinion
personnelle j'engage personne d'autre
qu'elle décorum à une fonction dans la
société dans toute organisation
l'ensemble des règles qu'il convient
d'observer pour tenir son rang dans une
bonne société et sur les vêtements
il n'y a pas de règles écrites par
tradition les hommes doivent porter la
cravate au salon bleu mais à part ça
ouais c'est vrai que de réglementation
est très large
on parle de tenue de ville comptera par
rennes ya sur la table aujourd'hui sur
la même chose
le président va donc lancer des
discussions sur le sujet moi je fais
confiance à françois paradis mais il
doit y avoir un certain décorum
je pense qu'on peut se faire remarquer
autrement que par son habillement par la
justesse de ses idées par la rigueur de
ses interventions
moi je vais leur laisser le choix de
leur habillement j'ai même pu remarquer
que la portée des documentaires mais je
pense qu'elle a alors remarqué que nous
mangeons
devoir improviser ça vient journée à
ottawa aucun code vestimentaire non plus
il n'ya que la tradition qui pousse les
hommes à siéger en veston-cravate en
2014 à montréal alex norris est expulsé
du conseil municipal parce qu'il ne
porte pas de cravate
le règlement est abolie depuis le
printemps dernier fin de l'obligation de
cravates aussi pour les députés français
venir à salbris et immédiatement retirer
ce gilet la seule règle officielle
instauré cette année c'est de ne pas
avoir de vêtements qui expriment une
opinion et de les porter correctement
merci quant à catherine dorion porterait
tel un tailleur si on lui demande et je
pense que oui mais est ce que c'est mais
c'est ça pourquoi on le ferait faudrait
mais les actions ça change au fil d
argent sinon on serait encore là bien
avec des perruques blanches n'y aurait
pas de femmes ont par là même si mathieu
prost radio canada montréal